It would be a tall order to weave the galaxy’s
most feared Sith Lord back into Star Wars
Episode 9, but the dark side of the Force
is a pathway to many abilities some consider
to be… unnatural.
So, how exactly might that happen?
Here are a few ideas.
George Lucas inserted Anakin Skywalker as
a Force ghost in the final moments of Return
of the Jedi.
Although it's always been assumed that only
Jedi could access this power, Anakin's last-minute
switch to the "good guys" must have given
him just enough positive mojo to earn a spot
beside Obi-Wan and Yoda.
Replacing Sebastian Shaw with a digitally
inserted Hayden Christensen in the special
edition still feels like a gratuitous revision
to the classic film, but it does crack the
door open for what might be the most likely
way for Vader to return in Episode 9, as a
Force ghost played by Christensen.
Whether offering counsel to Rey as a Jedi,
or to Kylo Ren as the new Supreme Leader of
the First Order, Anakin could still impact
his family's story one last time.
In The Art of The Force Awakens, concept art
from Episode 7 by Ian McCaig portrays Christensen
as Anakin appearing as a Force ghost, with
his face alternating between a human visage
and the mask of Vader.
This piece was created after Abrams came on
board as director, so it's entirely possible
he could revisit the concept in Episode IX.
Watch the Star Wars saga films enough, and
soon enough you’ll start to notice that
certain aspects of the movies "rhyme," with
certain plot beats echoing across all three
trilogies.
“Again it’s like poetry so that they rhyme.
Every stanza kinda rhymes with the last one.”
For example, there's a climactic moment in
each of the first films where a trusted mentor
figure dies unexpectedly.
Revenge of the Sith and Return of the Jedi
both feature unexpected character reveals
of some kind.
Will the pattern repeat?
Okay, so that’s probably a massive stretch,
but what good is a fan theory without some
grasping at straws?
“I’m getting too old for this sort of
thing.”
Following the reveal theme, Episode 9 could
feature a sequence in which a ghostly Vader
is providing counsel to Kylo Ren, secretly
guiding him toward a decisive loss at the
hands of the Resistance… only for Ren to
learn the ghost is actually the Force ghost
of Luke Skywalker, tricking Kylo to help his
friends?
If nothing else, it would be a suitable follow-up
to Luke’s promise that he’ll see Kylo
again at the end of The Last Jedi.
In The Force Awakens, Rey experiences what
would later be termed a "Forceback," in which
her contact with Luke's lightsaber gives her
a glimpse of both the past and future of the
Star Wars saga.
“That lightsaber was Luke's and his father's
before him, and now it calls to you.”
Filled with references to Star Wars past and
present, this sequence has provided fertile
ground for Star Wars fan speculators.
A flashback in Episode 9 would offer another
easy way for Abrams to introduce Darth Vader
back into the saga.
Kylo could get a glimpse of a pivotal moment
in Vader's life through contact with his helmet,
or another character could remember their
own encounter with Vader from the past.
One piece of old universe lore that has been
reintroduced is the holocron: a small device,
usually a cube, that can hold training and
insights from either Jedi or Sith.
When the holocron is activated, the recording
is played back as a hologram, similar to Princess
Leia projecting from R2-D2 in the original
Star Wars.
The holocron was introduced in 1991 in the
Dark Empire comics series and returned to
modern continuity in later comics and the
Clone Wars and Rebels television series.
It's a handy plot device, whether as a "MacGuffin"
to prompt a Jedi or Sith race across the galaxy,
or an easy way to cram in some exposition
through the broadcast of a long-lost character.
More interestingly, if Vader recorded his
own holocron of Sith insights, it's possible
Kylo Ren might have discovered it, and could
replay it in Episode 9.
In Revenge of the Sith, Palpatine explains
to Anakin that Darth Plagueis was a Sith Lord
obsessed with immortality who mastered the
ability to create life through the manipulation
of midichlorians.
Plagueis was once Darth Sidious' Sith master,
and as soon as Sidious mastered his own grasp
of this arcane art, he murdered Plagueis in
his sleep.
A single panel in the "Fortress Vader" storyline
from the Darth Vader comics series connects
this Sith legend to one of the biggest questions
in Star Wars lore, the parentage of Anakin
Skywalker.
We know Anakin's mother was Shmi, a slave
from Tattooine, but his father has always
remained a mystery.
In Vader's journey through Mustafar's mysterious
dark side portal, he has a vision of his mother
as Palpatine lurks just over her shoulder,
manipulating strange energies in her womb.
It's the closest Star Wars has come to implying
that the "father" of Anakin Skywalker is in
fact Emperor Palpatine, using the powers he
learned from Darth Plagueis to create life.
It's possible this knowledge didn't die with
Palpatine, and that he passed it on somehow,
either to his apprentice or within a holocron
or other vessel.
Kylo’s discovery of such knowledge would
set him on the path to mastering it and resurrecting
his grandfather.
It's very clear that Episode 9's filmmakers
could bring back Vader if they wanted to.
But should they?
It's a tough question.
On the one hand, this new Star Wars trilogy
has managed to cleverly fold in elements of
the past films in surprising and resonant
ways.
If they do bring back Darth Vader, it's sure
to feel significant and creatively fulfilling.
And if you view the total nine-film story
of the mainline Star Wars films as the saga
of the Skywalker family, then it would make
sense for the patriarch to return one last
time and influence the events surrounding
his grandson's rise to power.
On the other hand, Vader has become iconic
partly because when he does appear, it truly
matters.
Take that sequence in Rogue One, sure, it
was a nice excuse for an extended sequence
of Sith badassery using all of the special
effects and filmmaking skills the crew had
to offer.
But it was also a demonstration of Vader’s
impact on a moment of key importance to the
entire Star Wars galaxy.
If he had succeeded, the Death Star plans
would have remained in the Empire's possession,
and the burgeoning Rebellion might have been
snuffed out.
His failure had immense consequences for the
story as a whole.
Ultimately, that's the real question fans
should be asking about Darth Vader in the
run-up to Episode 9.
Not whether he can return to the story, but
instead what kind of monumental event could
warrant his reappearance in a galaxy far,
far away.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.